Hello I'm Arthur Mutambara from Zimbabwe.
I'm addressing the question of whether the
environment is going to lose out to the economy
in this year. First and foremost, I think
this is a wrongly posed question. It's not
an either or situation. We need to empoower
our ships and know everything about the environment,
know everything about the economy. They're
interconnected. In other words you can't actually
succeed economically without serving environments.
In other words we must understand the environment
as an engine for economic growth. We must
understand the environment as a platform to
bring about sustainable development in economic
growth which is spread across the different
nations on the world. Across the different
tresses of each country. So, no, the environment
won't lose out to the economy. If we get our
ideas clear, we are going to be able to serve
the environment. We are going to be able to
use several methods of energy, greener technologies,
to drive economic development. So there's
go to me a somatic function between to environment
and technology. You will not succeed in economic
endeavors unless you are to embrace the ecological
agenda. The climate change agenda. Also, in
the climate agenda, space. You won't succeed
in serving the globe unless you address the
needs of those who are victims of the economic
activities in this world. A poor starving
peasant in Dafur can reset the environment,
though it often causes commotion in that country.
So it's important that we address these matters
in a holistic manner. The environment, poverty,
HIV/AIDS, nuclear weapons, governs, that interconnected
what we seek to achieve. Our holistic solutions
that address all these matters. There is no
conflict whatsoever between the environment
and the economy. They work hand in hand. And
for us to have a sustainable economic idea
we can make model, we must address the climate
change agenda.